Cristóbal qué ha dicho la administración
biden y que se sabe sobre lo que va a
recibir Ortega a cambio
es una oportunidad para empezar un nuevo
diálogo con el gobierno de Ortega en
Nicaragua el departamento de estado
resaltó en un comunicado que esta era
una decisión unilateral de Nicaragua que
hasta el momento no se había conversado
nada oficial sobre que iba a recibir
también Ortega A cambio esta liberación
de estos 222 pasajeros Yo estoy en este
momento acá en el aeropuerto acá en
Washington donde ya llegaron y están
haciendo todos los trámites
correspondientes para empezar a salir
por esta puerta por llegadas
internacionales muchos nicaragüenses
están acá esperando precisamente la
salida de la lista de prisioneros de que
estaban en Nicaragua y que van a empezar
a salir en contados minutos desde acá
estoy Resaltar que el gobierno de
Estados Unidos dijo que esta era una
decisión unilateral y una vez lleguen
estos prisioneros acá pues van a tener
no solamente asistencia legal sino
también médica y el gobierno
estadounidense dice que les va a dar un
espacio ilegal por cerca de dos años por
razones humanitarias Cristóbal Qué se
sabe de Quiénes estaban en el avión se
conocen nombres específicos de las
personas que él como usted lo dice ya
están llegando a Estados Unidos ya
llegaron a Estados Unidos
Sí ya llegaron por el tema de los
radares aéreos podemos identificar que
ya le habían aterrizó que están haciendo
todos los papeleos y en la lista se
especula mucho sobre quién viajó Quiénes
son estos 222 prisioneros políticos se
conoce que son
periodistas que son
oposición política de Daniel Ortega y
varios medios han revelado algunos
nombres le doy algunos por ejemplo
Cristina Chamorro líder de oposición
política también Arturo Cruz Félix
maradiaga Lester alemán y también entre
ellos hay un ciudadano estadounidense
que pues ya está en tierra en tierra
estadounidense y pronto saldrán por acá
por esta puerta para pues empezar su
vida acá en Estados Unidos teniendo en
cuenta que Estados Unidos Les prometo
estatus